so listen man I want to start with
congratulations I know you're hearing it
from everybody let me join the chorus
thank you you're so good in this thank
you did you ever think when back we
spoke back in 2017 for Bushwick Bushwick
yeah at Sundance and I know back then
you were you know trying to do acting
and but did you ever think back then
that the next few years would bring such
diverse roles and you killing it in like
blade you know what I mean like the list
is just it's crazy right I didn't think
because I didn't assume but you know
when we had the conversation back then
you knew what I was after and so I I
wanted you know I wish for I prayed and
I asked and I sought after
but no I didn't assume it was gonna you
know come my way it was one of those
challenges I knew I was up against
breaking into Hollywood because people
saw me a certain way
and it was one of those things that
really uh I had to work at I really had
to you know kind of separate myself a
little bit from wrestling which you know
kind of sucked uh and at the at the time
I think a lot of people took wrong
um but I needed to do it to get people
to see me differently and it took years
and years and years of debt taking
smaller roles just to get people you
know like the role as you know in Blade
Runner you know I fought for that role
because I knew it was a good role and it
would get me somewhere and it would get
me to here and so no I I there's
something to this magnitude no I mean I
didn't
I didn't think it was going to come I
just kind of prayed and and hoped for it
so this role is so different than
anything you've done before and it's
getting to work with night it's doing
all this these dialogue scenes you know
it's not really action so I'm just
curious how much did you actually pay
night to be in the movie
[Laughter]
you know what's funny because when so
with our first conversation you know I
always kind of like get my Fanboy out of
the way and it's kind of hard not to but
I can't move on until I do and that was
one of the first things I brought up I
was like I love that he always pops up
in his films because people they know
that and they look for it and they're
excited about it and uh so yeah no I was
I was happy because we didn't see we
knew when it was going to be on the film
but until the film was put together we
didn't we didn't see it so when I saw it
I just started laughing out loud and I
kind of needed that moment of levity
because I was just
having so much anxiety about the film
and my performance and I was watching
myself and as I typically do just
cringing and that moment just gave me
kind of a sigh of relief and I kind of a
good laugh there it is that's his Cameo
um you have done uh you've done a lot of
acting last few years if someone has
actually never seen any of your
performances on film what is the one you
want them starting with with and why oh
wow
um
oh that's a big question because now I
feel like I'm going to dismiss any other
role
and by the way I want a caveat by saying
not this film because you're fantastic
in this thank you people are going to go
of the other roles and that's the thing
and it probably wouldn't be this film
either because I'd want them to see kind
of something that was kind of like right
in the middle definitely not like a lead
role but something like I always I
always go back to hotel Artemis for some
reason that I think it's because the
role it was different type of role was
me playing a character
oh it wasn't kind of me always being
that big badass he was like a big badass
but he also had a heart but it was also
I always associate myself with the
people that I'm working with and that
was such a strong cast like such a
well-respected cast it would probably be
Hotel Artemis yeah Drew did a really
good job with that I thought so as well
I was really proud of that movie so
you've worked with a number of directors
now how is night different on set than
the other directors you've worked with
he's a well I I have to say that you
know most of the directors I've worked
with like really big name Monster
directors who are amazing directors I
haven't worked with as a lead and so I
just spent more time with night we had
so many more conversations like in-depth
philosophical conversations
and so I think that was it I think just
that the time investment that you know
he had with me was greater than anything
I've ever experienced but also that his
direction is never simple he doesn't
give you simple directions he gives you
very complex very you know
conversational directions and it's a lot
to process he gives you the direction
you have the conversation but then he
lets you process it and perform it and
then if he's happy he's happy and if
he's not he'll come in we'll have
another conversation
so it's not it's it's weird he's not um
he's just not a typical director not as
far as anyone I've ever worked with with
but he's not
it's weird he's
precise
but he gives you a lot of information to
process so it's not very specific
detailed it's just a full-on
conversation I hope that makes sense no
um what do you think it is about end of
the world movies and television shows
that people just love that genre uh I
don't know man I think it's just it I
think it's a suspense I think it's one
of those things for yourself it's a
typical like horror movie you can always
you have somewhere to run you have
somewhere to hide and people will say
run hide but with into the world there's
nowhere to go
there's You're Not Safe no matter where
you run no matter where you hide you're
not safe if the world is ending so I
think it's that constant suspense it's
like a suspension there is nowhere to
run there's nowhere to hide you're not
getting away from this this is not a
character with a knife in his hand
chasing you this is the apocalypse this
is the end of the world one of the
things about this I read that there were
some of the scenes you guys were filming
were like 10 pages five minute long
scenes which is I'm sure for you
daunting when you're stepping on set
because you you know you're part of it
this Ensemble so how was it for you in
training if you will for this role
preparing for this role versus some of
the other things you've done there was
just so much more pressure I mean there
was so much more pressure because there
was or there was um not only that but
you know um Knight was also shooting
with one camera and it was on film and
nobody wants to burn up film we all know
it's expensive so there's a pressure of
that but also
when there's one camera and they're kind
of covering everybody if somebody of
Jonathan Groff is just killing it he's
killing and giving it is everything in
this emotional performance and then the
camera kind of turns your way and if you
blow it
that negates his whole performance you
got to start all over and you got to do
it again and nobody wants to do that I
mean these people are just they're so
talented and so beautiful and they're
giving these performances they're so
emotional that the pressure is on for
you to really kind of get sucked up into
that moment
and you know and bring your A game
otherwise you're just uh you're gonna be
a handicap to this cast and nobody wants
to be that person no completely
um I listen my most I uh while I was
really looking forward to this movie I
will admit my most anticipated film of
the year is a sequel to Dune uh I think
Denise is amazing yes and I definitely
have to ask you what it was like working
on the sequel it was it was you've heard
me talk about the first film we've
talked about the first film uh it was
that times a hundred because it was
Rabon amped up
and it was my part is much bigger on
this I got to spend much more time with
Denny which I crave for because I love
working with Denny
um and Denny again he just
Danny brings out the best in me and um
this was such an amazing experience and
I like I before I left the film and
we're talking about something else and
I'm not going to say until it actually
happens sure but he knows that my dream
is to work with him as a number one
because I really think that Danny will
show me how good I can be
um
but
this is so amped up from the first film
the first film was just an introduction
to what this film is there's just so
much going on that's so
it's so much more Cutthroat and
political and intense and there are
actually you know there are moments of
levity where there's some funny moments
and they're kind of absurd humor but
there are those moments so it's just so
much more amped up than the first film
um Greg Frazier shot it uh the sequel
like you shot the first one um I spoke
to him he seems very he's very happy
with how it turned out can you talk a
little bit about because I think his
cinematography is one of the reasons
those films are yeah why it's so good
yeah he's amazing and I love him as a
human being he's just a lot of fun he's
one of those people he's
he's really intense uh when he works
he's definitely focused but he's also
he's such a I think he's so talented
that you can just break away from it and
just take a second and just have like a
fun conversation and just talk about
nothing you know you can step away from
his work for a minute and just have a
stupid conversation about you know the
funny something funny you saw last night
you know but and I love that about him
yeah yeah
um also he did the Batman I mean the
list of what he's right it's it's and he
talks about the way I see that and the
way we put that on a pedestal and he
talks about it like yeah you know I mean
yeah another day at the office yeah so
I'm curious though um obviously now you
are doing more projects more acting have
you already thought about what you're
going to be doing this year like what
other films are you possibly getting
ready to do well I'm definitely going to
do the sequel to My Spy um because I
know that for sure because we start
later next month so I'm off to South
Africa to do that which I've been
pushing for for a very long time because
I love the first film it was just such
it was so much fun uh so we're going to
do a sequel to that
um I'm hoping that we I have a project
uh in the works with um Drew Pierce
again sure
um and we've collaborated on this film
called the cooler and it's basically
about um the life
this crazy weekend of this uh guy who's
a bouncer in Miami who was just trying
to redeem himself so it's that but it's
um
it's kind of a
it's kind of an after hours meets uncut
gems
so it's quirky and funny and suspenseful
and thrilling but also a lot of heart I
and I really insist on doing stuff
that's gotten you know hard at the core
of it is it definitely going this year
we hope so we hope so um
um Drew's uh you know he was busy on
mission impossible so he was working
with that no so now he's you know he's
got a few issues that he's dealing with
so but hopefully he'll start writing the
script uh soon on that note I gotta go
yeah congratulations on this yeah um
going to be a big hit